hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und bekam zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt heute machen wir rezepte aus
der kindersendung fingertipps
[Applaus]
eine sache fehlt noch
[Musik]
nicht schlicht
perfekt fingertipps war eine
kindersendung die auf superrtl 2001 ihre
erstausstrahlung hatte und seitdem sehr
beliebt war ich habe es als kind sehr
gerne geschaut wie der name schon verrät
konnte man dort sachen lernen die man
mit seinen fingern machen konnte
einfache koch und bastelanleitungen
allerdings manchmal ein bisschen robert
wan sowie die zwei rezepte die wir heute
ausprobieren werden mir fiel damals
schon als kind auf dass diese sendung
synchronisiert wird das heißt die lippen
haben immer nicht so ganz zu dem gepasst
was eigentlich gesagt wurde liegt daran
dass die sendung eigentlich aus
großbritannien kommt man das 1 1 tue das
nicht auf diese portion fisch und chips
gehört wieder essig noch salz drauf das
war es zb bei artec das gab es zwar auch
im ausland aber wurde in deutschland
noch mal extra produziert für die
deutschen kinder die bock auf basteln
hatten und benni weber hat es moderiert
und ich hab's einfach geliebt aber es
geht heute nicht um art attack sondern
um finger tips und die rezepte die wir
heute aus fingertipps machen sind
wirklich cool ich als kind hätte ich
schon gerne gemacht rezept nummer eins
der finger tips fish & chips tre kuchen
ein besonders wichtiges rezept das auch
noch richtig lecker ist fish and chips
ist typisch britisch deswegen können wir
deutschen jetzt nicht so ganz viel damit
anfangen obwohl ich gestern habe ich mir
pommes mit veganem fisch deswegen
gemacht und ich habe mich noch gewundert
warum ich plötzlich bock auf fish &
chips ab klar weil ich dieses video
vorbereitet haben aber diese sendung war
ihrer zeit voraus denn heutzutage sind
ihr motiv torten super beliebt es gibt
sogar einen netflix serien der es nur
darum geht ist es kuchen oder
das was es halt ist ein schuh oder so
die zubereitung von dieser motiv dort
ist wirklich ist sehr einfach und
deswegen legen wir gleich mal los
nein
ich habe heute meine zweite kamera
aufgestellt damit ich mich die kamera
ständig hin und her bewegen muss man an
diesen urlaub ist die anleitung für
ihren bizkit kuchen es ganz einfach
sucht euch ein rezept raus oder benutzt
eine backmischung aber wir machen
natürlich den biscuit boden selber ich
benutze in saly rezept aber und führen
soll biscuit boden brauchen wir
salz ellis vanille extrakt und die
einzige währung die noch teurer sei als
klopapier mehr so zubereitung schlage
die eier gemeinsam mit dem zucker salz
und wandel extrakt etwa 15 bis 20
minuten cremig die masse sollte er
voluminös werden so wird der biscuit
später super luftig locker siebe
anschließend vorsichtig das mehl oder
bei dem schoko biscuit mail und cacau
auf die masse und hebe es mit einem
schneebesen und achte darauf dass du nur
langsam und sehr vorsichtig von außen
nach innen unter hebst sonst wird so
viel luft aus dem teig wieder raus
gerührt und der kuchen wird nicht so
schön locker den teig nun in den markt
ein und streiche ihn vorsichtig gladbach
ihn anschließend sofort im vorgeheizten
ofen für 28 bis 30 minuten im den kuchen
boden aus dem ofen heraus und lasse ihn
fünf minuten abkühlen löse dann den bug
ring mit einem tortenring messer ab und
lasse ihn vollständig abkühlen viel spaß
beim nachmachen eure sally und während
unser kuchen abkühlt kümmern wir uns
schon mal um rezept nummer zwei wir
probieren diesmal ein schokoladeneis los
und wer hätte gedacht die zutaten für
dieses rezept sind bananen schokolade
und ich glaube sie haben zabel der
schokolade denn sie sieht relativ dunkel
aus streusel und ein stil bis ihr solche
rezepte sind einfach für mich gemacht
sie sind einfach schnell fingertipps
geschehen die banane ich weiß ja was
kritisch ist aber ich habe nicht so oft
das gefühl dass ich etwas kritisch wenn
da aber hat sich die szene gesehen habe
wie sie die banane geschält hat habe ich
gedacht die muss erst mal gespielt
werden die schale könnt ihr jetzt weg
werfen
vorsichtig kleid ist sie noch weit aber
nachdem sie in der sendung zwei sekunden
in einem fake kühlschrank drin war war
sie plötzlich hart in der sendung sieht
man wirklich die stelle an der banane wo
sie das so gegen die küchen gehauen hat
und wo sie aber nur in sound effect
drauf gemacht haben um zu zeigen jetzt
ist sie hart
daran und hat aber voll die das war
jetzt ein gefrierfach und jetzt machen
wir weiter mit unserer motiv torte an
mir ist eine kindersendung moderatorin
verloren gegangen so und das ist unser
discrete boden ich habe gerade noch den
kopf abgeschnitten und gemerkt dass er
noch ein bisschen warm ist deswegen dass
ich ihn noch weiter abkühlen aber wir
kommen uns schon mal um die
vorbereitungen das ganze soll natürlich
auch richtig frittiert aussehen und
dafür brauchen wir eine butter credit
macht man sich aus etwas butter etwas
puderzucker und ein bisschen milch klar
ihr nehmt euch 100 gramm von der butter
dann wiegt ihr euch 225 gramm
puderzucker ab und den gibt ihr zu der
butter
jetzt gehören dann auch zwei esslöffel
vollen milch reihen
glaub ich hab noch nie so eine art
buttercreme gemacht aber am ende ist
alles immer nur butter und sogar danach
hört man das schön kräftig durch
gleich geschafft
dass ein kind schaffen würde das tut so
weh hätte ich jetzt fehlen eigentlich
bloß noch die erbsen wie könnt ihr euch
aus marzipan rollen es sollte aber
grünes marzipan sei also wir können
marzipan benutzen oder fertig grün von
dort neben den fertig von der ich mag
bin ich den geschmack von von
neufundland fondant von dem geschmack
von fertig von der leyen ich bin keine
ahnung ganz viele leute mögen das nicht
und wenn es an dem kuchen dran ist
lassen sie es eher übrig es ist als
allererstes niedermachen davon wollen
wir uns mal ein paar kügelchen problem
ich liebe
und hier ist super erbse so vielfältig
worden ein kleiner tipp von mir wenn ihr
von dort anpasst und so dann könnt ihr
euch puderzucker auch an die finger
machen dann habt ihr nicht so ein
schönes gefühl bruder sogar speisestärke
speisestärke könnt ihr euch an die
finger machen und jetzt machen wir ganz
viele davon
[Musik]
so der abgekühlte kuchen wird jetzt hall
wir im besten fall lässt man natürlich
einen biscuit boden erstmal richtig
abkühlen am besten über nacht weil dann
bleibt er richtig schön hab ich aber
keine geduld und keine listen morgen
wieder diese töpfe zu machen denn die
tun bisher daraus schneiden wenn sie
jetzt eine fischfilet form das ist gar
nicht so einfach vielleicht lasst ihr
euch dabei lieber von jemandem helfen
ein ordentliches stück fisch
ist unser fisch ich finde es ist nicht
so groß ein großer fisch
marmelade aus dem ich würde meinen
kühlschrank video findet ist der
einfachste punkt den ich jemals gemacht
also kamera drauf und verschieben ich
glaube damit richtig lecker sein ich
habe aber auch schon wieder so einen
hunger unsere vorbereitete guter krimi
klingt
jetzt kann ich meinen fisch ein frisch
frittierten anstrich verpassen einfach
drauf schmieren das gute daran ist dass
es nicht so ordentlich aussehen muss tut
echter frittierter fisch ja auch nicht
kollege macht das echt einfach nicht
einfach nicht
ob ich das als kind hingekriegt hätte
vielleicht wird der größten ich lese
jetzt auch
man kann gar nicht glauben dass ich so
eine für der einwand heute mal gebacken
habe oder das ist mein fisch den man
hier wirklich schön wenn wir die bürger
nicht uns wegschmilzt das auch den rest
butter und zucker können dir dann auf
essen
diese nährwerte weiß auch nicht warum
ich lebensmittel in letzter zeit immer
so besser aber seit man selber park
merkt man einfach dass akten nur eine
verschiedene kombination von butter
zucker mehl aber der fisch ist natürlich
nicht alles sie haben noch den rest
kuchen den wir jetzt zu pommes machen
werden klar gemacht mann wurde
misstrauisch
[Musik]
dann lass das mal so ne pommes probieren
who haben wir hier unsere partner die
gleiche farbe wie die ja das problem
hier mit diesem pommes ist auch dass im
norden die bio-eier er gelb sind also
eine helle farbe haben und bioeier
woanders dann auch mal so und richtig
dunkles orange haben je nachdem was die
hühner zu fressen bekommen und deswegen
sehen meine pommes einfach zu gut aus
feuer und dann noch hier die erbsen
reinige
ein großer löffel catch a ha ha ha ha ha
und das ist unser erstes gericht fish &
chips als motiv torte finde es ziemlich
gut gelungen es ist ein sehr einfaches
rezepte sie ein kinder rezepte und für
die kinder rezept ist es wirklich nur
zehn von zehn weil das ist doch wohl ein
problem ist dass ich als deutsches kind
jetzt nicht so viel mit fischen chips
nahe doch in hamburg haben wir auch
zwischen chips gab am look ist auf jeden
fall cool und jetzt stellen wir uns
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmeckt eine fish & chips motiv torte
aus der kindersendung fingertipps
vom geschmack ist jetzt nicht die
raffinierteste torte die hier gegessen
habe passt aber auf jeden fall gut
zusammen mit aaron buttercreme man kann
sich wenigstens immer auch service
biskuit boden verlassen und ich bin fan
von von dort komme es hier kein licht in
dieses ketchup
die idee finde ich allerdings sehr
witzig also für so ein kindergeburtstag
kuchen kommen ist mit erdbeermarmelade
seid könnt gefeiert wird dir werde ich
heute noch viel spaß haben
olaf matalla kuchen zurück in den
kühlschrank und was holen jetzt aus der
tiefkühltruhe unsere bananen haye hatte
schon dieses ausprobiert es schmeckt so
gut einzige was mich daran stört ist das
ist oft der auf dem gaumen so hängen
bleibt dieses fette gut leiden aber
ansonsten ist sehr lecker und jetzt
machen wir den test können wir umdrehen
gefroren aber noch nicht glaubst nicht
so unsere banane ist vielleicht dass man
sagt
jetzt geht es bald aber was brauchen wir
denn jetzt für unsere banane die
schokolade und die sollte jetzt
schmelzen ich zeige euch auch gleich wie
das am einfachsten geht ich meine trikot
lade für meine zwei bananen
gute ideen wenn man soweit
roster hasen übrig hat irgendwann dieser
spiele zu machen die vegane poster haben
sind die ganzen angebote
so und jetzt brauchen wir eine große
schüssel und eine kleine schüssel große
schüssel keine schlüssel gibt es
übrigens bei ikea finde ich sehr gut
und sowas nun kochend heiß und das geben
wir jetzt in unsere große schüssel
dann nehmen wir unsere schokolade in der
kleinen schüssel und packen sie dahin wo
es
schwingt und das darf jetzt erstmal
schlafen
effekt das wasserbad für unsere bahn ist
fertig und jetzt gibt's eigentlich also
das ist ja hier wird ganz einfach
so einmal sein team sondern in unsere
weil das ist sie stellen wir uns wieder
der allerwichtigste frage wie schmeckt
eine gefrorene banane mit schoko und
streuseln ich kann es wirklich gerade
nicht sagen
frag mich nur was passiert dann dachte
ich er habe hier ist man halt nur der
gefrorene banane oder was
ein bisschen zu viel schokolade macht
was sie technisch ganz cool aus wie
seine frau die kundenprofile hat muss
man jetzt nur die banane gebrochen
probiert
hat 8000inc trend
gefrorene banane schmeckt einfach wie
banane eishockey hört zu was ist seit
kelly und ihr seid mal wieder auf die
ehe das schmeckt als ob man ein eis
essen würde
eine voraussetzung man muss kalte sachen
abbeißen können zehn von zehn
empfehlungen das ist so lecker wie man
könnte auch so einfach so tippen was ich
meine gibt dann dürft ihr eure
allerdings herein
man kann die arbeiten
ich kann können
ich konnte noch nie in meinem leben
irgendwas mit schokolade ist noch nicht
so gemeint haben gerade das war auch mit
dem video courier tritt vor allem wenn
die andere video vorschläge habt dann
schreibt sie gerne in die kommentare
denn so zeigen wie so eine phase da
brauche ich euch wirklich ich bin ein
bisschen ideenlos aber ich es kann auch
sein dass ich einfach müde bild falls
auch im urlaub es kann sein dass dieses
video online corp will bin ich
irgendwann im urlaub ihr abschied fällt
immer schwer chesnais
mach's gut durch im land geführt